Щось середнє між Дональдом Трампом і Сильвіо Берлусконі.
Так більшість сприймає головного претендента
на прем 'єрське крісло в Чехії Андрея Бабіша.
Мільярдера і медіамагната.
Прихильника жорсткого правління.
Щоб рухатися вперед,
потрібно, щоб влада була однією командою.
Лише така влада може вирішити проблеми.
Андрей Бабіш - лідер руху ANO,
що означає "Акція невдоволених громадян".
На виборах йому пророкують близько 30 відсотків голосів.
При цьому у найближчих конкурентів майже вдвічі менше.
Бабіш, як і Трамп, щедрий на жорсткі оцінки.
Представників традиційних партій
він, наприклад, називає - цитата - ідіотами,
а журналістів - бовдурами.
Багатьом чехам подобається такий епатаж.
Гасло Бабіша - "без балачок",
бо його виборці люблять більш авторитарний стиль управління.
Багато чехів розчарувалися в традиційних партіях,
хоча економіка країни на підйомі
і в Чехії найнижчий рівень безробіття серед країн ЄС.
Бабіш стверджує, що нинішній істеблішмент
загруз в корупції і обіцяє навести лад в країні.
При цьому його самого звинувачують в тому,
що в минулому він співпрацював з
чехословацькими спецслужбами,
ухилявся від сплати податків,
а напередодні виборів Бабішу
висунули обвинувачення в шахрайстві
у справі, пов'язаній з отриманням субсидій ЄС
на суму в два мільйони євро.
Це сфабрикована справа.
І, звичайно ж, наші опоненти радіють.
Я впевнений, що час вибраний невипадково
саме зараз, щоб вплинути на вибори,
і щоб у мене не було часу на кампанію.
Прихильники Бабіша і далі вірять йому,
і хочуть бачити сильного лідера на посаді прем'єра,
а противники Бабіша бояться згортання демократії в країні.
Він подобається мені,
тому що він виконав за чотири роки все, що обіцяв.
Ми боїмося, що втратимо свободу і демократію за Бабіша.
Ця людина бреше.
Йому не можна довіряти.
Багато хто побоюється, якщо Бабіш стане прем'єром,
то Чехія піде шляхом Угорщини і Польщі.
Утім, оглядачі запевняють, цього не станеться.
Очікується, що Бабіш критикуватиме Брюссель в тому,
що стосується біженців і реформи ЄС,
але не занадто,
бо його агрохімічний бізнес
багато в чому залежить від європейських субсидій.